An absolute beast with free speech.
I and, and I know the fucking line.
It's a private company.
It could do what they want.
Freedom of speech is about the
government and it's like, yeah,
but are you okay with that?
Are you okay with a faceless corporation?
Uh,
deciding what you can watch and see and
hear and who can speak based on nothing
but this arbitrary ideology that comes out
of a building. Like, I don't like that.
I want anyone to have the ability
to speak about anything they want,
no matter how repugnant it is. Like,
like meet it with a lively debate. Well,
here's the, here's a perfect
example. Forget Alex Jones.
Let's talk about what
we talked about earlier.
Laura Loomer versus Louis Farrakhan.
You, where's your consistency?
You've got to explain to me
how that works. How does,
how is it okay for the guy on Twitter
to be calling Jewish people termites?
I mean that that is, that's
something you exterminate. Yeah,
this is Nazi Germany type. Yeah, exactly.
How is that? Okay, that's okay with you.
But then, I mean, how about look, it's,
it's works that way on the left as well.
Like how about that guy that
just got kicked off of CNN?
Cause he was talking about the Jewish
posers against Palestine and that he's for
Palestinian liberation and they were
like, fuck you, you're done. Like this,
this decision that,
or the,
the thought processes involved in
decisions that they make is not based on
rational thinking and objective
reasoning. So arbitrary, uh,
you just don't know. It's based on which
way the culture swinging, you know,
and the culture is,
is swinging in a way that avoids any,
any possible accusations of racism. If
you think in, in any way she performed,
you're going to be thought of as racist.
You avoid that because there's some
people that say horrific shit about white
people. Oh yeah, yeah.
They don't get van literally calling
for their death and, and yeah,
they don't know that girl that got hired
by New York Times and it was a massive
uproar because she had so many anti white
things on her Twitter. Oh yeah, yeah.
The Asian girl. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
just all that ridiculous
left wing woke nonsense.
You're allowed to be completely
racist against white people.
Massive generalizations against
white men in particular. Yeah, it is.
It absolutely is discrimination.
And it's absolutely what you're
doing is you're being prejudiced,
but you're being prejudiced with a stamp.
Well, you've got to stamp of approval.
Yeah. You're allowed
to be. And I love the,
the just rules that are made up
that are ridiculous. It's like, ah,
you're a racist. I can't be
a racist. I am this or that,
or I can't be sexist. I
can't be this. I mean,
it's like who's making these
fucking rules up. Exactly.
And how come I am not privy to
any of them? Of course I can.
I can call on any of these roles.
Did.
The beautiful thing about that is that
hypocrisy will eventually bite them in
their ass. And people who are rational,
who listened to the argument against it.
And so you, you absolutely can be sexist
against men. Yeah, absolutely. Ken,
of course. And you are a lot of
feminists are 100% against men.
There's this feminist that I
fall her fucking Twitter picture,
the image of the big one. The banner
one says trust. No Man. Great.
Okay, well good fucking luck. Good luck
and cutting out half the population.
Don't trust them. How about trust
is all women you're going to do.
That will be great.
Congratulations.
Cause you got about 15
to 20% cunts and that's,
you're going to have to trust all of them.
Yeah. Yeah. Good luck. You got 80, 80,
85, 90% may be good gals and you've,
you got uh, your, your polluted.
We'll get a polluted population.
Just like men,
population of men is a polluted
population of women. If you,
if you thought that you were going to
get pure drinking water without dropping
in those, uh, purification tablets, you're
going to get charged some shit in there.
Yeah. You're going to get,
you're going to get sick. The,
yeah, that I, there's no, um,
there's no 100% on any of that.
So when we saw the whole believe all
women thing that happens during the cabin
hearings and whatnot, I didn't do that
bit the other night. Did A, uh, uh,
now tell it to you off air. Oh, okay.
I'll tell you something off here. That's,
it's, it's, it's crazy. Like
the idea that anyone would say,
believe all women is as mental is saying,
believe no women.
It's the same stupid thing because there's
going to be assholes is going to be
pieces of shit.
I was saying on the show the other day,
like no one really wants equality.
No one equality isn't good.
The,
the fight for equality is where it's at
and you never want to attain it because
then you're not special anymore.
If you're fighting for equality that
you're always a victim, there's always a,
an oppressor and you're
fighting that once you're equal,
you can be called a shithead. You could
be called stupid. Everything else.
You're just another face in the crowd
with another stupid voice that probably
shouldn't be heard. Uh, so no
one ever really wants equality.
No matter how much they're
clamoring to get achieved,
you're going to find some reason why
it's not right. Why it's not valid.
And you can still say that you're,
you're being victimized by something that
currency in it. Yeah. Yeah. There is.
There's, there's definitely equity and
being a victim and not being equal yet.
Wait, but you're fighting. You can say
things that other people can't sit. Right.
We see all the ties.
You can be completely prejudice.
You can do a lot of things you could
never do if you were another race.